klebsiella is a gram-negative bacterial
genus that can cause significant
infection in the human
pneumonia can be the causal organism for
pneumonia
klebsiella infection is generally
acquired during Intensive Care Unit or
ICU treatment because these bacteria
prefer oxygen
klebsiella has thick capsule on the
outer side which protects them from
macrophages and dendritic cells
this is ABCD of klebsiella a cool
mnemonic for you to remember the things
a for aspiration pneumonia B for abscess
in the liver and lungs C for curing
jelly sputum which is characteristic of
this infection D4 diabetes mellitus and
E4 etoh overdose both of these last
points are the high risk factor for
klebsiella infection as it's a bacterial
infection it can be easily treated with
antibiotics like carbon epims
fluoroquinones
Etc watch the full video to know more